celebrate israel a nationwide event
hosted by the israeli american council
is taking place at the west wind
drive-in in north las vegas tonight
madison kimbrough caught up with one of
the organizers of tonight's event
she joins us live now with what we can
expect when those gates open
at 5 30. madison
yes sasha this event plans to have
hundreds and hundreds of people
and then also a live stream concert from
israel later
in the evening fun activities will be
offered most of which you can do
right from your car as you drive through
usually celebrate israel host
thousands of people but the capacity
limit is at a thousand this year due to
the pandemic
israeli food music and vendors will be
also
front and center one volunteer shares
how this event over the years
has brought her closer to her rooms
normally this event
is the largest pro-israel event in the
state of nevada
we used to have it at the venetian for
many many years
so when i found out about this
organization i was like this is such an
awesome way to
make friends and you meet so many people
make connections
stay close to my culture it just
it makes my heart happy
gates open here at 5 30 p.m and it lasts
until
nine tonight now you must be registered
in order to attend we'll have all that
information
up on our website and you know it's not
too late to sign up as the event starts
again
at 5 30. reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now